[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
thank you foreign
[Music]
you guys should be able to hear me now
as you can see I'm alone right now
I got Fame coming in from the left
and I Got Dirt coming in resetting his
PC
so this is like the pre-pre-show
dirt is coming okay
I Know a Man
what's that song that that donkey sings
on Shrek it's a oh there there he is see
I told you dirt would be out here
momentarily
hmm
we live
someone's making
someone's making a joke about that okay
okay damn it don't you start
oh for the people I got a new anime
shirt it's an attack on Titan anime
shirt
got the attack Titan the Colossal Titan
the jaw Titan
um
I can't the cart Titan
the female Titan the Beast Titan and the
the uh the
the Warhammer Titan
oh so we got a weird every time I wear
is dirt how dare these people
oh you know how it is man you know how
it is so
uh
we got a crazy show for you guys man you
guys know how I do things I do things
differently we do on the IOP shirt uh
show uh show uh I guess I'll go ahead
and tell are you still confirmed this
weekend
yes I'm I'm open on Sunday so I will
tell you guys right now
dirt will be on IOP for the prediction
show but that's the only person I'm
telling you guys
you know normally I get kid but I was
like we're gonna get dirt off the
bleachers man we're gonna give him some
shots let's have some fun yeah so dirt
and King together this weekend on
Sundays
so I think it's a it's going to be
interesting I'm not going to tell you
guys the rest because we have a few
guests that's coming through
but I think you guys gonna enjoy it I
really do we got a a newer person that's
in the community he's been on this show
I'm not gonna say his name
but he's coming through too
actually don't say his name I'm gonna
mute my I'm going to mute myself in OBS
and I'll tell you about dirt
okay
he's coming on too
that's the homie you know yeah so uh go
have a good show man uh we having stuff
being made right now for the promotion
of it
and uh you know I got some people
pulling through too I think you guys are
going to enjoy it I really do I think
yeah I was going to enjoy it you know
the only person I'm telling you guys is
dirt because dirt's here
and we're we're gonna really Captivate
this thing unfortunately the week after
that I'll be gone
I I we won't be not having an IOP not
next uh next Wednesday when I be an IOP
an an attic show because I will be
in New York
no I did not say plume I don't know why
you said I said plume
um you guys are just ridiculous five
dollars you would try
eman2537 I just want to thank dirt for
covering the Glee from the cut the
Google Dome I think that's what's
causing my cataract the the chrome dome
I'm assuming he's talking about the the
the the glare from my head because I'm
wearing the Hat because my basement is
extremely cold in the summer when the AC
is on it's like freezing down here bro
so I'm wearing a skull cap he's he said
I I'm covering my scope my my my my
glare that's what he's trying to say
yeah technically Matt I should be bald
too I got that we see the hairlines like
back here okay it's crazy how many men
lose their hair like I try to lose my
hair at 18.
I was in Young Buck
it's it's it's like
it's like they do that it's like
genetics do that on purpose you know it
got we we already have a hard enough
time as it is okay we gotta deal with
hair loss on top of that gotta find out
a two dollar super trap from gaming
Forte
uh two dollar Super Chat from uh
adidas20 zero Dirk got me here what's up
Adidas two dollar Super Chat from game
before dirt podcasting in the alley in
that cast Corridor yeah okay I don't
cast corner see y'all knowing about that
it's it's a little rough over there
background I had to take that down
kind of got to move on you know
yeah so we uh let me resize this a
little bit so we got Fame entertainment
in the house
what's going on man doing pretty good
man hey that's my first show being on
with Fame man is the first time together
I think so first time we got the dirt
dang I think so what's happening bro
you've been messing up that's I I take
the blame on that take the blame on that
appreciate the invite at it yeah always
welcome man you know we we especially
what's been going on here you know
what's crazy there is like a down spiral
bad PlayStation news and it's like it's
like a roller coaster and then there's
an up spiral Xbox yeah man it's funny
how that happens isn't it yeah cause we
had a pretty bad for about a month
already huh
well I'm getting the bald stuff already
in the chat no we were talking about men
being bald
oh okay yeah I'm going bald two dollars
from Crazy Horse is that dirt's new logo
don't y'all start man the show just
started damn it
so we we got a pretty uh pretty bold
show to go over we're just going to do a
predictions I'm gonna do how I did last
year because I'm I'm unoriginal I you
know if something works I I keep doing
it hey man let's stick with it brother
if it works stick with it
all right so what I'm gonna do
they obviously they don't have the
Activision one here yet because uh
that's still up in the air that's gonna
go through
but
we gonna act like it went through
no so what we're going to do is I'm
going to uh
I'm gonna put this on on the screen uh
I'm gonna send you guys this link
okay
accidentally okay I'm gonna send you
guys this link and and zoom
and we're going to go
from like top left to bottom like you
write a book
okay so we're gonna go through that all
right this is how we're gonna do it guys
I guess I could put it on the screen too
let me put it on the screen because
maybe you guys want to see that
uh
uh let me just go ahead and put a
regular uh screen capture because I
probably still want to see our
our picture on here
let's do this
all right so here's what we're doing
guys
let me put this up here
okay let's not click on random stuff but
I don't okay there we go boy did that
Undead lives not go to the right place
oh I was about to say I was like what
what are they not telling us
all right so bam
all right can you guys see that fine
yeah all right did you guys click the
one we're supposed to click
yep all right so all right so let's top
left the bottom
first thing you want to do is we want to
start
with our good old friends over there
at 343 Studios all right I I wanna you
know what I want to start
I want to start with with fame fame it's
343 gonna be here in any way shape or
form
I hope not
um I truth be told I mean until three
four three and this is no shade because
I love Halo I just actually re-installed
the multiplayer gonna get back into it
um
unless they're talking about all of a
sudden 343 is working on a new IP I kind
of don't want to hear from three four
three I need them to kind of sit in a
corner work hard do your thing and let
it be unless you're talking about a new
IP I don't want to see I know it's gonna
be it's gonna be worth uh you gotta you
got a Halo game that isn't that old half
current seasons going uh Xbox showcase
without Master Chief is weird right now
unless you let's talking about a story
DLC which we have ruins the story DLC
might have been canceled unless you're
bringing that on yeah but if you're just
trying to show a little highlight about
the current season of Halo infinite I
could care less uh either you give me a
new IP from the studio or you give me
DLC if I had to guess I say we I say we
do hear something about the story DLC
because they have to continue that story
that's just me so you okay so let's say
you don't want them to be there do you
expect them there though because I do
think that's two different questions
I don't expect them to be there okay so
I don't think they have anything to show
we got a zero from three four three what
do you think Dirk
I think they will be there excuse me um
I think they will be there just to show
a trailer
uh for the new season and of season four
so I think they will be there but they
won't be there in a big capacity just
you know just a little small trailer
um for season four
yeah so let me throw you guys with
something man I don't think it's gonna
happen let me throw you guys with
something
once if they show that season two of the
new Halo show
no
thank you
you think that's a wanna see no movie I
don't want to see no movie or TV show
trailers on the game showcase you know
none at all
I know you I'll tell you guys on that
all right so gotta find out super try
from drawing TJ I want to see gameplay
stay the K3 it's been five years of
development we'll get to that here in a
little bit
uh I do think they're gonna be here I
don't want them to be here but I do
think that
they've had a lot of good momentum and
them as a PR Company would be stupid not
to show them on some way shape or form
maybe they'll open I don't want them to
open up with it you know
they'll go into
the open up with X which you know we'll
get into opens and closing because you
know Cox says I'm real big on that
because I feel like
it's just a matter of what we saw going
into the PlayStation show when we saw
that they didn't open up with Spider-Man
it was fishy because that means
neither Spider-Man's in the middle or
they're ending with Spider-Man you know
that the the this opening of a Showcase
in the closing restore of a showcase is
extremely important and people don't
give it enough credit they act like it's
not all right so
I do think it'll be there now I don't
want it to be there and I hope they
don't show it there because that means
they'll put more time to other stuff but
I can understand as long as it's good
and fast I'm okay with that
all right
do we really need to talk about world's
Edge does anyone here care about Age of
Empire
no I don't think it's I don't think
they're going to be here at all though
I'm going to be wrong I don't think I
don't either well is it is Age of
Empires
yeah
was it out coming out is it is that on
Xbox yet I have no clue
I mean I I could I could see them I
could I could see it being part of a
scissor reel if anything
oh and I want to point out to the people
I'm not doing time stamps for this this
is a prediction show you watch the whole
thing you don't watch it at all
time Mafia coming after you yeah I mean
maybe I'll fix it up I don't know
coalition
what's going on with Coalition man
we're starting let's start let's start
with with dirt this time man Coalition
the creators of gears
I I want them to be here
but I don't think they're going to be
here I think they will be next year I
don't think they're going to be here
this year
I think they're
working on gear six obviously uh but I
don't think they're gonna be here this
year they're going to have you know the
Xbox has some other stuff to announce so
they got to stay with like say some
stuff for next year but so no they will
not be here this year
okay um
that's interesting what about you
Fame do you want them completely
obviously
I want them there Buckle number one
they're going to be my replacement for
three four three you got to have the
three four three order Coalition there
right I'm saying three four three one
I'm saying the Coalition wheel and I
want the coalition to be there because
gears files released 2019. yeah uh late
2019 October September or something like
that so we're looking at going on four
years since
gears 5 released it's time for a trailer
I'm I'm fully expecting a return to
horror theme gear six trailer it may not
be gameplay
but I expect some sort of return to
horror style gear six end of the trilogy
end of the franchise type filling and
trailer at the Showcase is is this is
the second Trilogy and it's it's this is
it this is it
this is it
I hope you're right but um I agree
um I think it's been long enough we
could see a Gears of War trailer and you
know I don't think they're going to be
there but I want them there because I do
feel like
Xbox One They Carried the whole
generation on their back and I I do feel
like this would be about the time you
see stuff but I think what makes this
different than previous years is
Microsoft's in a better situation where
if they don't want to they don't have to
show too much that's not coming out soon
you know even if they show which we'll
get to here in a second Fable even if
they didn't show that
they could easily show that next year
because they got enough stuff to show
this year the only reason I want them to
show Fable and we'll get to that in a
second is because I want that one and
done one-two punch to PlayStation
all right so let's let's let's move on
to compulsion games oh start with Fame
what's the we happy few
what's what's going on man
this studio is how to eat it's been even
longer since their title which was 2017
2018. uh over the years they've really
built up their Studio it's gotten out
it's gotten a lot bigger since they were
bought out by Microsoft
um
I don't think the title they're making
is show it is going to sound bad
is going to be showcase worthy I think
we're going to see something separate
later on whatever time I don't think
they're they're their title will be here
I I it's time right we're looking at
almost six years since they made a game
um I don't think whatever they're making
um and I said it's going to be bad I
just don't think it's going through
something that's going to take up time
at a showcase
um so I don't expect him to be there
even though they should
I don't expect them to be there
what about you Dirk
I I'm the exact opposite excuse me I I
do believe that because they're
literally the opposite everything yeah
one of us got to be right yeah I do
believe there will be there um like you
said Fame they haven't done anything
since 2018 we happy few you know they
had a couple of DLCs but for the most
part they've been growing like you
mentioned under Xbox and I'm expecting
them to be there with their new game and
I do believe their game will be a
a a bigger Style game um I remember Tim
dog was on wbg uh a couple years ago and
he mentioned he heard that compulsion
wants to do
a triple A game they want to be a bigger
Studio yeah so I'm expecting that David
is a little back and forth with
Microsoft in them they really fought to
incr to make their Studio bigger yeah so
I'm thinking their game is going to be
bigger than you think Fame and I do
expect that game to show up here now now
with the release date probably next year
um but I do believe the game will show
up here
whatever it's going to be called
obviously we don't know yet I think
compulsions game probably will be here
but I do think it's going to be a
smaller IP
it was just it was a nightmare
development it started as something
changed into something they got a
publisher changed it again but when you
look at like the world of we happy few
and what that game represented it was a
fantastic experience it's just you can
have a great outline but if you don't
execute and say the right things in that
outline it's pointless
if you get the cliff notes of we happy
few it sounds like an enticing story
very engaging story but then when you
play it yo this ain't it yeah I I
couldn't get into it but let me ask you
this adequate now you say small the game
is it Hi-Fi Rush smaller or pentiment
smaller high five Rush smaller high five
rush I can see that I can see them I can
see that yeah so that that's right I
believe those principlement games are
more for the bigger Studios who Branch
off a small team than make a small game
anybody the size of compulsion and them
shouldn't be making a sentiment that
should be coalition had a group of 10
developers who wanted to make a game
then you go you're gonna make your
pencil this time I do feel like and I
know I'm not in that scenario and I know
it's hard to manage all these people but
I do feel like you you should have you
should get the right to make smaller
titles like that like you should show
that your studio can make quality games
depending on you know the the size of it
and like obsidian making grounded
impediment makes sense because obsidian
has made fantastic games you know uh and
I get it sometimes that their mindset is
if we give these developers
opportunities to work on different
projects and IPS they'll stay in the
studio because they're they're flexing
that creative muscle but at the same
time there is a thing is like you know
checks and balances you know you
shouldn't reward bad behavior when it
comes to making some of these games
because you know look at like redfall
you know as much as you know some people
like redfall I've personally felt like
it was very underwhelming you know if
that team wanted to work on a side
project I would be like no you they got
to prove themselves to make a main
project first
so let's let's move on to
double find
oh you know as far as compulsion I think
I uh we got into a side step of the
thing I do think a potion is going to be
there and
um I just don't know what kind of size
it's going to be or if it's going to
come out this year it just depends well
but let's let's go on double fine double
fine made like um
cycle knots three you know they made a
game I really like on massive chalice
and you know it's a really fun like
strategy kind of x-con style type game
where you're fighting these these
creatures throughout time in existence
so I really enjoyed stuff like that but
you know let's let's start with with
dirt on this one you know double fine I
would say is probably one of the most
prominent students they have they can
make they can make high quality Double
A's at a quick consistency do you think
they're here
um and do you want them to be here I I
do want them to be there because I love
the double fine I love Psychonauts too
but I don't think they're going to be
here I uh psychonized 2 came out of 2021
you know it's a couple years uh but I
don't think there's a rush to show that
new game
I do not think they will be here but I
hope they do though
okay
um let me get the Super Chat real quick
fight on subtract from Chef leak leak I
don't know man yo Dirk this Anthony Ward
f for GCA good to see you doing your
thing it's crazy you an iron Lord bro
what's up man yo how you doing brother I
used to uh like host basketball
um like maybe 10 years now um at this
Middle School like he didn't play but I
do remember him yo what's up bro how you
doing man that's what's up good to see
you man so
it's a Fame
double fine
what's what's your thing
and the great words of Dallas man who's
the voice you hear every Sunday and
Wednesday double fine double time double
a batteries Doublemint twins trying to
jump my anatomy if you don't even like
you shouldn't have the audacity all
right hit the like button but double
five won't be there
double five won't be there we agree
Dallas's bar is out there the Dallas is
one of the hardest working meet people
in this industry man got bars for days
I'm gonna throw one of his bars out
there yeah I agree I I don't I think
double fine I would like double find and
rare to co-develop a Banjo-Kazooie game
but I do feel like you know someone in
the chat said they're working on AAA
product they are one of the studios that
I would be I would feel comfortable as a
consumer of an Xbox ecosystem that they
can work on multiple games at once
because I feel like they they kind of
Define that and that's what they do and
I think you know they're probably
working on a double A maybe a triple A
maybe even like a couple Indies they
could be working on three or four games
I would love to see a Brutal Legend too
though yeah it's just one of those
things where it's like I believe in that
studio and I think that they're gonna
deliver what they want to deliver
um you know we could talk about Xbox
game publishing but I think that's so
I think Contraband will be there oh
you're saying Contraband gonna be there
do you want it yeah because yeah you
gotta see gameplay yeah oh absolutely
oh you don't oh damn
what about what about io's game you
think IELTS game up get a trailer
I don't know see the the problem with
that is
it depends on how much of their stuff's
ready
you know for all we know see the the
crazy thing is Microsoft said at this
position where a lot of these games
could realistically be ready like got so
much stuff and I don't know are they
going to take away from this show to
give the next year's show and I know
that sounds real wild at this point but
in most some of these studios are
working on two games
and maybe three in some occasions it's
just it's it's interesting man it's
interesting all right so you know I
think we can all agree Xbox game
publishing is is a wild variety of games
that could come out there uh from from
like third-party stuff to second party
stuff but the initiative is definitely
first party
dirt is the initiative there
in 2024 there will be but not this year
yeah I kind of agree and I think at this
point we could we all want the
initiative to be there but they're not
going to be there I don't know part of
me don't want them there because I don't
think they're ready
what about you
it's crazy uh that we we on the same
page again Dirk because I don't see them
being there I think I think the studio
had
that's setbacks with those with so many
people leaving and you know them working
with another I already prominent Studio
I don't think it's ready to be shown I
think if anything it's a candidate for
the game awards kind of fun okay let me
get this super chat I missed thank you
John TJ five dollar Super Chat from John
TJ love your uh content addict don't
give in to the people that want time
stamps uh unfortunately uh drawing TJ I
already I already gave in I'm already
writing this timestamps
I guess you get this other one you said
um
drawn to David if I want to see gameplay
three yeah five years in development oh
you got that one oh no it's cool
um when it comes to initiative I agree
with you guys there's just no way you
know this Studios went through a lot of
turmoil uh I would be very surprised if
they're there in any way shape or form
I mean plus you can't show everything in
one year you know what I'm saying you
can't show everything because remember
in 2016 the PlayStation did that and
they had the same games in 2017 and 2018
do you remember yeah that's why I prefer
them to keep this closer yeah yeah
absolutely you know you don't got to
show me all this stuff up but let's move
on to Exile entertainment you know
apparently they're working on AAA
products you know Fame
Triple A Product supposed to be like
some cyber Punk kind of stuff I feel
like they should be working on a Fallout
that's me uh what what do you feel Fame
what's what's going on with you how far
are we from here next from uh
um Wasteland three how long ago did that
drop that was 2019 19 yeah because that
to me that's that all that's always my
Kicker like when when did they release
that last game it's foreign
that's still three yes
getting it to full production this this
game is whatever they're making isn't
ready to be shown I don't think they'll
be and that's the crazy Microsoft Xbox
has the best problem you could have as a
game publisher right absolutely Studios
we've had so much time of not getting
things from their studio so now it's
like all right four five six seven years
in the past now all of these Studios got
something that's either ready or about
to be ready everybody
we're looking to probably get into full
production in 2022 yeah I don't think I
don't think we're going to see in NX out
there I would hope but I just don't see
it yeah I I agree with Fame and uh Fame
is absolutely right with what he just
said this is a great problem for
Microsoft to have you know unfortunately
you know we had to deal with years like
2022 where it was super dry but to know
that all of these Studios was sometimes
you gotta walk to run there you go bro
so yeah but I agree I don't think
they're going to be here either
but it's okay you know I'm saying it's
okay that's another good point
um that I saw someone brought up in the
chat
do you guys think we see that Halo br
no
yeah I don't either
if Halo shows up
ah
Maybe
I I
are you okay if they show Halo in that
form they show that Halo br
a so that's that's your your caviar it's
like okay if you're gonna show Halo you
better show me something brand damn new
um yeah okay and as I was saying either
the the story DLC which we hear it was
tall so that's unlikely I would want it
there someone I saw the channel I said
about season Four's trailer give us the
BR
like we know what's happening we know
it's real show it even if it's just a
scissor reel show it okay so we got a
little off topic with that but I thought
it was a good engaging thing I did I ask
both of you of Exile
yeah you did okay just making sure
Mojang we agreed Again Minecraft gonna
be here
no I don't think either what do you
think
yeah I don't want them here you know
what's funny I never want them here
I'm the same way it's nothing against
the studio and I feel like that you know
they're definitely making the money but
it's just like fam how many years am I
gonna go see Minecraft on this stage
exactly like remember the days of the of
the shows where we'll have like filler
time it's like people playing Minecraft
I'm like Bruh Bruh it's gonna be a bad
showcase bro if we spending 10 minutes
playing Minecraft I remember those days
remember that the the VR the AR VR thing
that never happened yeah bro you know
what's crazy if you really think about
it the stuff that Microsoft Loki lied to
us will not lied they promised something
they never uh you know they ended up
canceling it was the the AR or virtual
reality thing they never done and like
the the to making Minecraft like 4K
Graphics or whatever that was remember
that yeah but they never did almost it
never came out yeah they canceled it
yeah
that's fine 4K update yeah they should
do that on the series X
yeah they should five dollar Super Chat
from Predator H2O why is no one talking
about cryotech they are really working
on crisis four we'll get to third party
here in a second man we're right now we
get into the bread and butter
Ninja Theory yes
[Laughter]
100 hey I know you don't watch sports
but you know Charles Barkley he's a
guarantee
guarantee hellblade will be there
what do you think Fame
yeah
um especially if it releases this year
this year's game of the year will be at
uh the Showcase
but if anybody followed me you know
since 2017 I've been fanboying uh you
know hellblade and hellblade 2 has been
my most anticipated game since 2017. uh
it would be my personal Game of the Year
whatever year drops Garen guaranteed
it's going to be there it has to be
there with with actual real gameplay I'm
sorry what we saw at the game awards
wasn't gameplay that doesn't count it
was just her run that was gameplay sir
that was gameplay it was gameplay but it
was the gameplay that we want let's be
it was gameplay but it's not the
gameplay we want even when we see some
actions what's funny is after they
showed that I went back to IOP the
following week and they were like oh
addict you know how did you feel about
this how'd you feel about that they
showed me the thing I knew it's gonna
look good
uh two dollars Super Chat from Don
diotaku you forgot Shaolin and Ballard
beltree the Xbox public yeah yeah yeah
whatever he said
those are the uh like those are two
titles that jazz I believe Jazz
um said that Xbox is working on some
type of Wu-Tang game and the other one
yeah yeah
trying to get a hold of them so yeah
we'll see what happens man
from uh Chef leak predictions gameplay
of the CGI that was shown in 2020 avowed
Fable states of Decay 3 ever while
something from Contraband perfect Dart
what else are we not asking at this
point two Stark or two in Motorsports
and surprise Killer Instinct that'll be
a 10 out of 10 show bro it would it
would you know it's funny he he didn't
even uh he didn't bring up yeah he said
Fable that is like I'm gonna be real for
your Chef I think I think you're asking
for a lot I think I think you're setting
yourself up you own boom predictions
right now okay
uh so you know I mean when it comes to
this here's how I feel about what comes
to the Ninja Theory I want solid
gameplay in a release date that's all
like that's all I asked for
solid gameplay release date now we're
going to go into what what we think is
going to open and close the show here
soon but that's all I want from them
solid gameplay release date show us how
the gameplay has evolved I know they've
been hiring like God of War developers
that did combat design and stuff like
that solid gameplay and a release date
oh I've seen
upset um yes
yes about they have to oh yeah yeah wow
of course right right of course
absolutely 100 yes yeah so yeah what do
you guys expect from about
I'm expecting it to look great and and
obsidian game um I love their games
um I'm expecting a good showing some
solid gameplay yeah I mean that's what
I'm expecting bro because
um this game has been cooking earlier
I'm gonna say oh release window
I want to release date ain't none of
that release window nonsense
it's definitely going to give us it's
definitely going to say 2024.
it's those 8 20
24.24. that's it if it gives me 2024 I
Riot come on
what they're gonna have to do is they're
going to have to I don't see it's
getting a lot of gameplay
um but they're gonna have to they're
gonna have to give us something to build
the story like tell us what this game is
it's gonna be maybe a few seconds here
that gameplay won't be a lot but it's
definitely a 2024 game and they're not
going to give us
I think Xbox might be a little a little
bit gunshot of giving dates so far out I
think you're gonna see a lot of game
good initial like Montage gameplay and
then you're gonna see dedicated shows
later on in the week to that game
kind of kind of like you know the the
second show that Paris used to host I
think you're going to see stuff like
that you know they're gonna do that
again this year yeah I think they
already uh said that they're going to do
it again okay and I can see that yeah so
it's just like one of those things where
they're not going to want to give a
bunch of time to one specific game
they're going to do more stuff for give
a general emphasis on what the game is
and then they're going to push that onto
someone else to break down some more
all right
playground games
I mean it kind of confirmed it they
didn't really confirm it but they
confirmed it so it'll be crazy someone
said if it's a glitter controller
bro oh
come on don't let me do that no that
would be that would be terrible man
glitter controller I Riot two dollar
super trap from Swagger uh swaggy GC
shout out to my boy fam
hey hey that's love I appreciate it
appreciate it yeah so I mean when it
comes down to that man it's just like
okay here's what I let's break the Fable
thing down a little bit this just
happened recently you know it's funny I
have a prediction video I where I really
dig into my thoughts on the prediction
show and you know I actually wrote a
script guys I don't do that
I'm off the top addict okay I was on the
paper addict that day
so it but I had I had to redo the show
because initially I said Fable wasn't
going to be there
and um they put in there
you know which I I did hear rumors that
Fable might be at the show
but you know how stuff like that goes
you never know what's going to happen
what is going to happen it's always like
random
so
what do you guys want from Fable I'm
kind of curious on that what what do you
guys particularly want from Fable if it
is there
anyone go first frame
I'm gonna keep it short and sweet I want
the Fable feel that looks like The
Witcher I agree an adult version of
fable yeah I don't think we're going to
get that because of the glitter
but I I would like a more adult Fable
that does do like very
crazy stuff now part of me feels like
that's the only way to truly evolve the
brand you know because when I think of
fable I think a cause and effect I think
of you know the world morphing to what's
going on in the game I don't think that
I can fart in someone's face is faithful
and I think a lot of people think that I
get it the British humor is is a hundred
percent in the game and I'm not saying
take the British humor out I'm just
saying tile that [__] down
um
I'm expecting
um I I want Fable to just blow people
away
like
remember when hell blade uh 2019 even
though it wasn't gameplay but just that
seeing it blew us well oh my God that's
that game is going to be incredible even
in at the vga's uh in 2021 like oh man
that gameplay looks incredible
do you guys remember Matt booty had an
interview a couple years ago I forgot
who the interview was with but he
mentioned
um I wanted to play I asked playground
games are they ready to show it or can
we show Fable and they said not yet I
don't know if you guys remember that but
when Matt booty said that that is
letting me know that this game is going
to look very impressive
yeah and I know stuff behind closed
doors I can't really go into because
when you talk about like certain
development stuff it's easy to track who
who said what depending on what's said
and I was asked not to say nothing but
like
they got like a Halo size Budget on
Fable like they're not playing around
and if you think about it they've been
working on Fable since 2018. yeah yeah
because when and probably before that
maybe 2017 when it was if when it was
actually started I remember yeah I
remember in our room were way back then
yeah
because Phil Spencer came out when they
said they bought all those Studios and
he said 2018 yeah he said and they're
going to
put their image on another open world
franchise but we'll get into that later
he kind of made it seem like they're
going to talk about it later on in the
conference
so it kind of upset me when it wasn't
there let me get these super chats
because they're going to get out of
control
um let me make sure I didn't miss anyone
behind it okay I did okay five dollar
Super Chat from Don diotaku you ever
think back to when Xbox publishing made
them Fable Tweets in 2021 and just be
like what that uh what the f was that
about I still need answers are you
talking I don't know what he's talking
about do you guys know what he's talking
about I don't remember he said in 2021 I
don't remember uh go ahead and add uh
the iron Lords podcast Donald Super Chat
and tell me what you meant by that two
dollar Super Chat from Jay three of my
favorite YouTubers keep this panel I
appreciate it man
what's up Jay two dogs at home from
Raiden blade dirt Spider-Man 2 Venom
Suit needs your level uh your your level
retweet
I feel like it's an inside joke yeah nah
man you know what how dare you
Raiden blade don't go to sleep
take over for a second we'll get water
hey uh call weed with the two dirt Xbox
is about to hit their stride boys yeah
man you know attic said hey Fame my
attic said uh a few weeks ago Xbox was
getting their legs beat we us as Xbox
fans I you know I have PlayStation
Fanboys brought it all through my chat
with the CMA blocked the deal and the
red fog got those terrible reviews and
now it's like yeah like you said uh we
never said that I don't know what you
talking about a week later PlayStation
getting their legs beat and I'm loving
every minute of it this Dracula fan put
back to back did you guys see what
frontega did to me
it was amazing but I watched it a couple
times it was hilarious oh my God they
did my man Jayden I'm dirty in that
stuff
yeah I'm I look I'm not going to say I
put Jade up in there intentionally for
the for for the clowning because it
could have easily went the other way it
could have been cloudy on King but it
didn't so and Jada knew that was the
possibility going in so
uh I don't think he knew it was gonna be
that bad but bro that was oh my God oh
my God two dollar Super Chat from Raiden
blade I can't wait for TTS and you and
Sean on CMA expose FTC
yeah man we're gonna have some fun
drawing TJ the two live subscribers are
you Venom yes yes I am
that comes with a paycheck that's what
yes it does okay so playground games
do they show CGI or they're gonna show
gameplay that's the biggest question
last year we got just nothing
it was nothing it was well well when
they announced Fable it was just a ferry
going through the wind right right
uh I don't I don't foresee gameplay
obviously a nice trailer
um
I don't know man with them doing the
whole glitter thing
you know what we can gameplay full-blown
reveal and and but no release date I'm
going all in putting my feelings out
there we're going full-blown Fable
everything I try there you go they
dropping draws that that that's that's
what I said because kind of talked me
off the cliff like he was let me drop
you back on the cliff they dropping
draws you know what you know what Fame
I'm jumping down there with you yeah man
I'm falling in the sky like look like
Zelda is so like link is in tears of the
Kingdom man got my hands out like this
don't got no wings suit don't got no
glider it's either they do what I say
imma hit that and splat that ground
we all thought PS gonna curve Stop Xbox
wait okay maybe dirt didn't but um no I
didn't I was nervous I was nervous
because I was like man two years I was
like two years and no showcases they
gonna have some stuff and I was watching
that show I I couldn't believe it
the whole time I was in denial of the
whole time
bro after they showed that that Gran
Turismo trailer I said oh
the fight I was prepared from the angry
therapist we better get some gameplay
and not the Halo gameplay we got
um I think
if we saw a gameplay to that degree do
you think it's fair to want a release
date
or a release window release window
window yeah yep see because I still
believe Fable is probably 20 25 so if
they show I'm starting to think it's 20
24 now if they really show fable
already
I still think they can get it here's the
thing they oh they're gonna show Fable
next year Eddie at their show next year
to me why are you showing a game where
you could easily just hold it back you
you got plenty you got a vowed uh you
know um Hellboy 2 you have Starfield
coming on right after it you have plenty
of stuff that can Captivate people
go above and beyond and put Fable in the
show randomly if it's 20 20 foot I'll be
like six years of development maybe if
it's 20 25 I think fable
wouldn't be in the show but if it's 2024
holiday
or maybe they difficult a war it's
coming out 2024 holiday in the delay
maybe it's possible we got a couple
different that's a great dude that's a
great point though so you're saying I I
do believe they're going to show
something this should show some gameplay
this year maybe not a lot but they're
going to show something so you're saying
in your opinion by them showing some
gameplay this year if they show gameplay
this year you think it's coming out next
holiday
yes
at it I mean if you don't mind if you
don't mind I was gonna I just want to
backtrack just a little bit because
there's something I I wanted to say and
I just remember what it was with the
Coalition I think we'll get that that
gears collection on PC
hmm
they better not come on that stage and
announce something coming to PC
PC only
yeah it better be on everything
I just don't like I don't mind them
announcing like a game coming to PC
don't use that stage to announce stuff
only on PC I hate when they do that like
there's a PC game show for that go over
there and outside they need the help
trust me have you ever seen a PC game
show
do you guys feel Sony's doing too much
Spider-Man especially the games feel
like they could become generic like
cause yeah yeah I agree and I'm not
being a bot right now but I do think
there is a little Spider-Man fatigue
um three years I mean three games in
five years
and and you don't even see like a huge
difference in like the way they look I'm
sure the game is going to be good you
know don't get me wrong I'm sure it's
going to be good but there's a little
Spider-Man fatigue I think
and the fact that it looks like it looks
like Spider-Man remastered
not saying that looks bad it just looks
like a remastered it looks good yeah it
looks good but you know call that game
DLC to the day he talked and listen I
recently finished Spider-Man Miles
Morales like maybe a few months ago and
that game was beautiful
and in Spider-Man 2 it looked like more
the same I still think the game's gonna
be dope great game but I do believe
there's a little Spiderman fatigue I
mean like I'm just mentioning this is
the third game in five years
I agree all right so let's move on to
the next one when it comes to uh
rare I don't think none of us think
we're gonna be here right nah unless
they show a sea of Thieves um
is going to be here in expansion I think
that's for the second show good see if
these are starting I'm getting like the
Minecraft like I don't I don't want to
see see if these yeah I agree with you
Frank I agree you know Microsoft
expression has enough Studios that do
games as a service they can literally
dedicate an entire show every year to
those games you got
Fallout 76 Elder Scrolls Online
Minecraft now Minecraft Legends you got
um cfp CD State of Decay because they're
still updating that to a degree yeah
grounded grounded like they literally
could do a whole show on those games
Microsoft do a whole show to those games
don't don't let them don't don't put
Don't Play Station yourself okay
all right so um turn ten I think we can
all agree it's gonna be here yep oh 100
100 guarantee guarantee
Undead laughs
gonna be here
that's a good one no sir you know what
frame I'm leaning toward I'm I'm leaning
towards no also I wanted to be there
because bro that's one of my most
anticipated games next to hellblade
I love State Decay too and and like the
latest update is dope man um but I agree
with you Fame I don't think I don't
think it's going to be there either all
right so uh let me get the supercharger
quick two dollars super shot from Don
diotaku uh hp2 gameplay was 2021 uh
Hellboy 2 and it's releasing 20 23 2024.
uh yeah I could feel you on that I still
I still think it might be early 2024.
for some reason
um I hope it's 2023 that would be fire
it'd be a dope year but I'm still
leaning towards it being 20 20 or early
2024.
which will be fine also
all right so let's get into these
Bethesda software
um these Studios uh Bethesda game
studios I don't think Starfield better
not be at the base show I don't know
anything to Starfield related I only
want to see a controller
yeah I think that they do they show the
controller they'll show it at the direct
the Starfield Direct
alpha dog
I don't even know what they mean don't
let me know someone in the chat tells me
what alpha dog makes I know someone you
know that's 614 people in the chat one
of you know what the hell alpha dog
makes I don't know are they the mobile
developer because I know there's one of
them over there do they make mobile
don't they yeah do they make the shelter
game The Fallout Shelter game Who makes
okay
how you doing okay there we go they
ain't gonna be there they might be there
you know how mobile makes xenomax online
Studio
they're the people that make um Elder
Scrolls Online
I'm gonna be honest I don't well I'm
gonna put my foot in my mouth never mind
they probably will be there with some
new expansions Like a Star Wars MMO
they're making or something I don't know
or maybe I just said something I think
they will be I don't know
I think they will be there because like
like ever since Xbox has owned ziti Max
P Hines have come both of their shows
he's been on stage talking about updates
for Fallout 76 and Elder Scrolls and
stuff like that so yeah I do think they
would be there five dollar Super Chat
from Alvin and in the the kind of funny
interview pairs listed nine games Phil
said we'll see most of them not some
most but I think they are showing a lot
you know we're getting expectations
that's the last thing we'll talk about
uh so let's let's move on to Tango game
work Studio I don't think they're gonna
be here nope and because even if they're
doing some kind of like DLC for Hi-Fi
rush I think that's for the second show
yeah
it
who Ed is it time for Doom yet oh we
need to come out 20 years I don't think
they're making to him
what are they making quake
yeah I think they're nice
I can see them but I can see them you
know dropping Quake because uh what was
described to me is the the god Slayer
whatever that was called that expansion
for Doom that ended that finished the
Dooms uh storyline I couldn't made no
laugh for me um I finished the the game
Doom Eternal but that DLC was whooping
my bro
like a really bad game
and like no no they they didn't make it
someone else made it it's like a it was
like a game just like those old games
and they made it and people were making
funs to do that always like says dumb
stuff
Duke Nukem oh Duke Nukem yeah yeah see
I think that was like Ed needs to make
that game but don't see I feel like they
it is as
found a way to crack that fast gory
gameplay yeah and they're the only
people that can't I in in my uh I in my
mindset they're the only people that can
make games like that
yeah all right so
Arcane Studio
no listen they need to hide in the
closet for a little bit
I'm gonna say they're gonna be there
I'm saying they showing up with this
song three now so let me know Leon will
be there yeah yeah yeah that would be
that would be dope that would be dope
I know I'm probably wrong but I'm
putting that into existence right the
hell now yeah that'll be dope
because like that flu came out of 2021.
so it's definitely possible two dollars
from ten dollars from drawing TJ did you
guys forget state of the K3 has been in
development for five years we will
definitely see something because we saw
the deer trailer for in 2020 definitely
need to see it I'm not going to go into
too much detail because I don't know how
much is public and how much is not
don't they might be there yes but if
they're not there just know that there
has been turmoil in the studio
that they weren't developing for that
entire time there was a lot of you know
you you saw like almost I just put it to
you this way
everyone I knew that worked on State of
Decay 2 no longer works there so
and you guys remember out of pax we went
to a state of decay party there was all
the devs there I got to stay to Decay
jacket
70k2 jacket every person I saw there
no longer works there yeah no sure could
they be there yes I would say that
there's a chance that State of Decay
three's there but to me they need
another year five dollar super shot from
Gabriel in game is game uh Xbox please
do another show drop hold the line you
know the members in the chat man put
hold the line in the chat if you're not
a member in the chat become a member of
the chat and put hold the line in the
chat you know King needs his Generals in
his armies man if you if you guys yeah
can it be infantry then what you gonna
do what
attic and dirt uh I appreciate you boys
unfortunately I have to dip
my guess for the evening it seems like
it's already in my in the Discord
already for the show uh we got Jeff
Grove coming on in about 30 minutes so
it's gonna be a hell of a song on your
way out tell me your your mic drop
moment
my mic drop moment
um oh ah shoot uh you know what I think
Xbox starts their villain art and that's
going to be some third-party game I'm
talking Tomb Raider level Style game
that's another third party uh that's
that's normally multi-platform that will
announce to be exclusive to Xbox they
have won full-blown villain era might
drop to end the show that that last game
won't even be there it'd be something
that they that they got uh exclusive I.E
tumor like I like like Tomb Raider
they're villain Arc I love that all
right man I see it I send the people
your way
hey I appreciate you man see you on a
bit see you
all right so we said Arcane machine
games they gonna be there I think
they're working on Indiana Jones songs
yeah no I don't think they'll be there
yeah I agree I don't think they're gonna
be there yeah
uh let's look here
and roundhouse uh Studios I I don't even
know what they work on I think they're a
brand new studio that hasn't really done
anything yet yeah so you know we're just
gonna have to see what they do in the
end
let me go back to what we are doing so
we we got some other stuff for you guys
hold up
there we go
now let me
get rid of this and then transition
there we go guys all right so we got
we we what we in hour and three minutes
so let me do the timestamp police
because I'm trying to be nice to the
time sent police
an hour
and three minutes
because I I was generally scared when
you said they're going to come after me
so I started doing it
yeah five dollar super shot from drawing
teacher I believe King David no ps6
their show makes it look like they need
Cod it did make yeah you know what it
did make it
put some hold the lines in the chat man
hold the lines in the chat all right
second party and third party stuff if
you do have a a a drop the mic moment
that is the second part of your third
party maybe a marketing deal timed
exclusivity anything in that nature hold
it because we have a drop the mic thing
next okay all right so
what is your anticipation when it comes
to marketing third-party stuff there
what is your anticipations for that
um
I'm trying to think of some third party
games that's going up I don't know man
um I didn't even think about the third
party
portion of of the show because you know
in today's time Xbox has so many first
party Studios that's what my focus is
but
uh for a third party game man
I don't know bro what comes out this
year because we saw Assassin's Creed on
Playstation show we saw Alan Wake on
Playstation show Ellen week 2
what other third-party games dropping
this year big third party game
I don't know maybe there's third party
games that's not been announced like
Ubisoft yeah maybe they got to Splinter
Cell stuff and that gets shown there
yeah it's true it's a lot of different
opinions that could happen when that
comes to that I think when it comes to
me I'm on this
I think they're doing really bad in
terms of marketing
and they need to do better on securing
high profile marketing rights to game I
agree I agree wholeheartedly you know
once they grab the card one because
I do feel that Cod
is big enough even if they don't get the
acquisition there's going to be enough
turmoil there
for Activision where they they're not
going to want to work with PlayStation
in terms of like marketing rights I
think even if if Microsoft doesn't get
this deal
Microsoft will end up with
the marketing rights anyway I agree
after after 2024 I agree with you
ugly special Nick is saying The Temper
expectations absolutely not I'm not Tim
I'm not uh I'm not setting back any
expectations it's not happening like
here's the thing
even if my expectations
destroys me
I have every right to feel like they
have enough stuff that should be far
enough in development to show you know
it'd be different if I was saying yo
dirt
they gonna show Dragon Age eight
GTA 6 timed exclusive gonna be there
to me those are unrealistic expectations
everything I heard does not sound un
like unrealistic expectation I agree
his high expectations for any other show
and that's another thing this is this is
a big show it's not a small show
and the thing is is like it won't take
much you show okay let's just what would
you want to say
I was about to say it's an hour and a
half show so they are going to have some
smaller announcements obviously they're
going to have some Indies some stuff
like that it's not going to be an hour
and a half full of AAA bangers you know
what I'm saying but I'm looking forward
to you know this show
yeah I agree with you it's just one of
those things guys where it's like
I believe and have an unrealistic
expectations and realistic expectations
I feel like for the most part we've kept
it realistic everything we said maybe
won't be at this show but it's realistic
that it would show up at another show
I've never said you know now the mic the
drop moments you know there's going to
be Mike the drop realistic and personal
ones
and maybe that would be a little bit
more going over the bar but it is what
it is on that part but let's let's go
ahead and and move to
this thing that I like to call
we an hour
and eight minutes
I like to do this in COG Cog laughs when
I do this because I put he says I put
too much thought process on this
all right so
the next thing is going to be the show
formation
what are they going to open and what are
they going to close the show with
um the crazy part about this show
formation is there
they've already pretty much said the
hellblade and a valve is going to be
there and a lot of their other Studios
can realistically show up at this at
this event
so what do you personally want and do
you think they're going to open and
close with
um
what I want and think that they're going
to open with is hellblade 2. I think
it's important to get the show off to a
great start
um and I believe that will be a a like a
showpiece of a game
now what they're going to end with
you know what I take that back what I
just said they're going to start off
with a vow
I think they're going to start off
yeah I think they would start off with a
vowed gameplay and the 2024 release
window
um what they're going to close with I
don't know
um
I don't think they're going to close
with fable
I think Fred was going to be somewhere
else in the show
I'm thinking they're going to close with
something unannounced that's Xbox first
party or even the second party deal
it's gonna close with something
unannounced
cheers for Mandingo mcthickins yo dirt
because what else is realistic oh come
on man
find another superchef angry therapist
mic drop give me killer insane versus
Mortal Kombat it'd be crazy if they went
out there and announced they bought
um another realm that'll be ridiculous
that would be crazy I doubt that would
ever happen yeah that's that's what
you're talking about unrealism right
that's our realistic stuff right there
yeah exactly bro uh okay here's how I
think
what I want them to open up with where I
feel like the show would really
Captivate
is open with Fable and closed with hell
play gameplay
but that's only if they have that much
confidence in Hell play game boy right
if not open with Fable and close with a
vowed
because I feel like they're gonna they
might want to close with a Val with
hellblade because I think there's a good
realistic expectation that this game
comes out this year hmm and that's the
reason they would want that's the last
thing you deceive but
if Fable does have a good showing
and they put that time date on it they
might end with fable
if they have something special that they
want to show people I don't know what it
would be I have no idea
but you know we'll have to see five
dollar subscribe from Don the otaku
Starfield Forza Motorsports about
Hellboy 2 Fable all confirmed or teased
by Xbox themselves that alone is setting
high expectations 100.
that's why when people say temper your
expectations nah we ain't hearing that
because the same people telling us to
temper our our expectations we're saying
the PlayStation show is gonna be fire
okay you write it you kind of right
[Laughter]
so that's that's what I personally felt
like but the crazy part about this is
they might open up with a new IP
could be compulsions game see the good
thing about being an Xbox gamer in this
in this ecosystem right now
is I have no clue what the hell they're
gonna do there's just so much stuff
that's not been announced
and so much stuff that's been in
development for three plus years right
that any of this stuff could show up
mm-hmm
and it's crazy and I think you know
that's why it's you know that's why you
see Xbox people making content and
Playstation people talking about Xbox
people there you go because we we got
stuff to talk about we got I've been
making a video almost every day yeah man
off of Xbox content for the most part
sure I have a couple PlayStation uh
Movie videos
yeah they're in the news because I I
have uh I have a masters in Xbox and a
bachelor's in PlayStation so there you
go you know I'm gonna talk a little bit
about you know it's gonna there's gonna
be you know I I'm stirring a bowl full
of green soup but every now and then you
know I get the salt in there like there
you go there you go hey let me say this
right quick
E3 2019 right
I was like so hyped for that show and
that show was a dud Xbox E3 2019 but if
you think about what you just said this
is four years later
at that time all of those Studios they
just purchased and of course this was
before zenimax
they were either like doing multi-platz
or their gangs were way too early to be
shown 2019 here we are four years later
those Studios that they purchased back
in 2018
those some of those students are ready
to show some stuff man and I would say
that you would have seen a lot of them
before them for the pandemic like the
pandemic pushed a lot of the industry
back six months to a year yeah and I
think that's the reason you're seeing a
lot of these PlayStation games not being
announced not being shown ghost Shima
too A lot of these games were in early
development when the pandemic hit and
they were pushed back six months to a
year and you had a lot of PlayStation
games at the end of development and it
pushed them back a little bit but they
were so far it was easier to go to a you
know a work from home kind of scenario
because a lot of the bulk of the work
was already done absolutely you know yep
I agree five dollars from drawing TJ
special Nick is only right half the time
and that's on the good day temper
expectations what a joke I agree we we
ain't temp we ain't tempering nothing
over here we got a two hour we Xbox has
most exciting pipeline in this gym I
will absolutely I will 100 agree and you
know after we saw that showcase from
PlayStation station I was convinced the
reason they did that is because they
were about to they they about to they
about to they about to do that two-piece
but really like they hit they hit us
with like Styrofoam like gloves like
you're right like you know you're like
you know so funny I say PlayStation road
map right is Spider-Man Wolverine and I
will always mention factions
I can't mention factions in that road
map no more I could mention fair game or
Concord two games as a service nobody
knows nothing about that still super
early but the road map is looking a
little spooky man Deliverance brought up
my shirt so yeah this is my shirt I I
said at the beginning I don't think you
guys so it's an attack on Titan shirt
you got the attack Titan here the jaw
Titan here
the the uh
the cart Titan here you got the Colossal
type the dolphin and then you got the
female Titan here the Beast Titan here
and the Warhammer Titan here
all right so I think that's all we can
really talk about when it comes to that
hey yo hey yo Knicks will you tell me
what what PlayStation world map look
like then since I'm overthinking things
I'm overlooking things go ahead tell me
go ahead
we got I'll wait go ahead put it in the
hour and 15 minutes
all right let's let's let's let's talk
about the end man
mic drop moments I want your realistic
mic drop moment and something that you
particularly would be a mic drop moment
to you that might not be realistic
but please don't say like buying active
like what if I told you both of these
Hold the Line
what if I told you my realistic I can
hear you mic drop oh okay
my realistic mic drop moment and my
unrealistic mic drop moment is the same
thing
geekhead just said it
Killer Instinct
if they somehow announced a new killings
thing that would be a mic drop moment it
can happen
technically it can happen
it's somewhat realistic but then then of
course it's very unrealistic for it to
happen oh but that would be my mic drop
moment I think I said this last year too
but uh yeah now I think about it man
we've been on the show for a year here
because I remember being on your show
doing this show last year
um so that'll be my my job moment addict
I don't know if you heard me yeah use
the Killer Instinct killings that's both
my my realistic and unrealistic mic drop
movie
oh man
um
my realistic mic drop moment would
probably a fable release date for next
year holiday
I think that would really Captivate a
lot of people my unrealistic mic drop
moment would be
a big Japanese jrpg exclusive to the
platform and in Game Pass like the
Persona 6 showed up on the platform on
the stage and they said it's exclusive
to them oh yeah that's really awesome
yeah two dollar super shot from James
Thomas the deal for an exclusive
Gauntlet game uh that's cool
I feel like they need that kind of
scenario and I feel like going up there
and announcing a game like that would go
a long way for them we got 650 people in
the chat hit that like button guys
figure the angry therapist oh okay will
you grab that real quick with the five
dollars PlayStation road map TV TV TV oh
and a movie
there was you being messy man once
uh it would be crazy if they show the
Halo season two trailer bro I will be
pissed
I will be pissed they're gonna say you
show Master Chiefs Master cheeks
I would be pissed they show something
like that man no even if the show was
good I wouldn't want that you're right
here I actually enjoyed it it wasn't
great but I liked it but no I don't want
to see that
yeah I just feel like we've gotten to
the point where something like that
would really go a long way and I get it
it's not I would say that's like a
mid-range because I can see like if I
said like
them buying Square Enix for that I I
would say that's really unrealistic but
if they're right I do think if that
PlayStation didn't secure the
exclusivity for Persona it would be more
realistic than not you know that's why I
said like Persona I feel like they can
if they if they're able to they can
actually work at a deal for Persona and
I think that's one of the things they
need they need more of a a market in
that they need more of a fan base that
does those type of games and in order to
get that sometimes you have to invest
and I'm not saying that they need to get
it all this time I'm not saying they
need to get all these games another
banjo another mic drop moment to me
would be a Banjo-Kazooie reboot you know
I love that I don't think that's
I feel like that's not realistic either
because I have heard like you know
little rumors that they are working on
Avenger Gazoo in some way shape or form
you know the biggest thing I just want
them is I want
I want Fable to look good that's my
biggest thing you know I think it will
bro just playing around right now you
got
fable
avowed
Hellboy II
Forza
and one damn show
and one show yeah how do you drop the
ball
you just gotta make sure the games
actually look good that's the most
important thing yeah if if those games
all of a sudden didn't have a good
showing which I don't think would happen
but if those games didn't have a good
showing then that would hurt but uh yeah
but I believe playing around games
man I I just feel the game is going to
be a technical
masterpiece
I trust them when it comes to you know
um how a game looks I know this is not a
racing game obviously but I'm expecting
it to look great bro and we already know
hellblade 2 is going to look great and
yo I want to win that game project Mara
is is going to be shown
I don't know so my our last topic is
going to be showcase
final
thoughts
there we go so my question to you Dart
you know we're going to go ahead and end
with this
is what what is your expectations and
your final thoughts on this show
well
um my expectations is to
gain some momentum back I feel Xbox they
lost well they had some momentum earlier
this year with Hi-Fi rush and and like
some of the positive news and they lost
a lot of momentum with red fall and the
CMA blocking the deal so I'm expecting
this show to
getting some of that momentum back and
especially when they have the
opportunity because the PlayStation
lackluster show
to have no like the entire industry eyes
will be on Xbox that day
and they have a solid show
I believe a lot of people will look at
them a little differently okay Xbox you
guys are showing us that you were you
know you're you're ready for you know
like the Xbox has no games narrative is
done that's what I'm waiting for because
for uh for the Xbox has no games
narrative to all of a sudden starting to
be PlayStation has no games is
incredible so Xbox has to show us that
they have games and they have solid AAA
games that's being developed they have
some double A games being developed they
have a portfolio a diverse lineup of
games that's on the way and that's what
I'm expecting from this showcase
and that's it brother
I just
let me get these super chats real quick
before you God I think there was one
before that
we got a um no I read that two dollar
Super Chat from God's Hitman they better
not be hyping me up for no reason we'll
get to that statement a second five
dollar super trap from JD gamer
netherrealm and TT games joining Xbox
and we're getting not only Killer
Instinct but a Killer Instinct and
Mortal Kombat crossover and a conquer
Bad Fur Day two uh Day remake part two
uh I agree okay here's the thing about
God hitman's you know and I think that
would be the best way to announce you
know another room just to announce that
they're making a Killer Instinct I don't
think they I think the best way to do
you can't just make a killer in Stick I
think the best way to bring notoriety to
that brand is if you buy another realm
you say we're going to combine
Killer Instinct with more combat for
this game you know killing each versus
more comic then their next game is is
more combat
um uh look they better not be hyping me
up for no reason
dirt did I did did we you know people
always say
Xbox not hyping up the fans the fans are
hyping up the fans dirt did I put up the
uh the Fable teaser
no you did
did I um did I go I was extra like Aaron
Graber and buy a a you know a Hold the
Line shirt
no you didn't and that's my thing it's
like these Executives do it just as much
as we do and I know they get paid to do
it and you know for the most part Aaron
Greenberg does a really good job when it
comes to hyping people up but you know
I've seen him pull people back in the
past yeah be realistic this isn't gonna
happen
wouldn't that Fable thing came up even
if it wasn't Fable and it was something
else maybe it was foam Stars too for it
they didn't correct anything mm-hmm
and I think that's my thing is like and
no I ain't paying attention what what
Dirk's saying I'm I'm commenting on the
Super Chat
to me
we're hyping things up because we're
just excited
and it doesn't matter how many times we
would hype things up to to to Oblivion
and back we're still going to Hype it up
I think it's okay man if you ride with
them listen bro
um in this community people gonna make
fun of you regardless
you know I'll be made fun of you'll be
made fun of King Dave everybody's been
made fun of that's how this community is
uh the PlayStation guys they roll with
PlayStation last weekend
the show was an also people made fun of
them in the past there's been lackluster
Xbox shows
people made fun of us for hyping to show
up in it and the show being a letdown
that's just part of of the of the nature
of being a YouTuber man so if we hype it
up and the show is the L it's a l we
move on people talk trash I hike that
redfall
I hyped it up I was excited for it I
love Arcane the game did what it did
Sue I hiked up to see him maybe
um passing the deal two weeks ago on on
my Monday show I had a thumbnail said
CMA is going to approve it was done Baby
K deal and then Wednesday morning the
opposite happened people let me know in
the comment section yo this did not age
well you dumb Xbox it's a part of the
territory so us hyping it up
if they let us down they let us down we
move on if they let us down we'll just
we'll just go in my on Twitter for a
couple of days yeah I might hide for a
little bit just like when the CMA uh
blocked a deal I was
it's like they always hide me they
dropped the ball on the show we just
hiding them like a week later they
announced that the deal for Activision's
going through and we just come off a
hammer
that's it like you said like we
mentioned several times this podcast
two weeks ago Xbox was being destroyed
two weeks later PlayStation is being
destroyed it's upset knowledge is a
roller coaster it happens all the time
right the industry is extremely fast
yeah like extremely fast that's why like
when people say we're gonna fix the game
and you know fix it like we're gonna
release the game and fix it later no
you're not you're going to release a
game and the game's gonna die later
because in this industry unless your
games as a service and there's very few
games as a service that actually do it
correctly games don't get second chances
like that very often
yeah so and look I finished red fall
and I can sit here and tell you as a fan
of Arcane games
that game was a solid six out of 10. the
reviews I mean it was just I don't I
don't understand what happened with that
game I finished it with open mind
it's a solid six out of ten bro
I hear you so you know we're gonna go
ahead and close out of here do our
closing statements uh you know we an
hour
in and
27 minutes you know we won't be back to
the week after next next week I will be
in LA
so
King will be reacting to the show uh not
next Sunday but the Sunday after it'll
be king and Saul because King solvent uh
and kit smooth will be there that's only
people I know as of right now and I
think you guys are going to enjoy it man
you know we'll be I mean cargo gonna try
to jump on after the show but we don't
know what kind of like
area we're going to really be doing it
at so it's going to be hard to jump on
just off the fly like that
five dollar supercharge from JD gamer
LED an Xbox is after aware Hold the Line
shirt during the Showcase let them say
something like we had something special
for y'all that held the line that would
be crazy that would be intense once a
film Spitzer comes out of a Hold the
Line shirt
you know because I I don't think it's
going to be live but if it was live and
someone had to hold the line sure I
would lose my absolute [__] like yeah I
Gotta Give me one bro okay give me one I
have soft sand you want send me your
address so you know
I want to thank everyone for coming
through we had 650 people in here at one
point in time hit that like button on
your way out you know dirt where can the
people find you out what do you got
going on
oh man um I'll probably do a one-man
dark man tomorrow you know I love to do
them on Thursday now um got TTS on
Friday I'm on PTA K blam show on
Saturday and I'm on iron Lord Sunday I'm
busy the man this week man
yeah so uh as Dirk said we're gonna have
him on for uh King uh for the prediction
show this Sunday it's going to be a show
going on I will say normally we try to
keep it just to Xbox but King is very
admin I think he's being very extra
about wanting to talk about Ratchet and
Clank coming to PCS so I I think we're
gonna have to talk about that a little
bit at the beginning but I've been very
vocal I don't want to spend more than 15
minutes on that topic uh five dollars
from T from YT two Sony showcase was
very weird they didn't show Persona 3
remake or Jet Set Radio even though it
was already leaked at Xbox get them
interesting you know that's why I say
that's why I don't think just
saying that I think there's a good
chance that we might see a Persona IP at
Xbox is like a huge stretch
you know it'd be crazy if they announced
Persona 3 and then went into persona 6.
it would be a good look and I think that
would improve on their marketing
strategies I think it would do a lot of
stuff but you know I won't appreciate it
you know spam that link in the chat
Dart spam it yeah man yeah check out my
channel
yeah you gotta say the sucker
you job turkey
does say some crazy stuff in that
I'm not gonna lie he does some crazy
stuff in there all right you know I
appreciate it for coming through you
know we're gonna go ahead and send you
guys over there to to fame you know
think first off thanks Fame for coming
on to tell them uh ad extension you know
uh the attic show sent you go over there
and have a good time I'm sure they're
gonna have a messy show you heard Fame
at the beginning and even if you don't
want to go over there and watch you
you're busy go over there and hit that
like button guys it's good the the
channel is going to give you the prompt
to just go over there so just go over
there hit that like button and take off
when you got something that you gotta do
but appreciate everyone coming through
this is the Lord addict
and dark gregadine be sure to check my
videos I made today about Fable yeah
check out the video and can I say one
thing hey Nick stop crying man okay
that's it
peace guys
next stop crying